trigger warum in diesem video geht es um
sexualisierte gewalt gegen kinder
bilder die ihr nie veröffentlichten
würdet hatte sich ja auch auf dem handy
was für ein gerät anfangen die fotos
selbstständig zu durchsuchen und die
infos darüber an die regierung schicken
bei uns vielleicht ein schnappschuss auf
dem im hintergrund jemand so aussieht
wie ein international gesuchter
verbrecher anderswo eine
regierungskritische smim oder vielleicht
eine regenbogenflagge die horror
vorstellung von datenschützern und
datenschützern ist deine geräte könnten
das bald selbstständig suchen und dann
an die regierung melden das iphone würde
also zum iphone eines whistleblowers
etwa zehn odenwald jedes iphone wird
sich selbst durch suchen nach was auch
immer apple will oder nach was auch
immer apple vorgeschrieben wird zu
wollen wir müssen reden über eine
funktion die apple angekündigt hat und
in der viele eine gefahr sehen
eigentlich sollte diese funktion jetzt
kommen aber die kritik daran die war so
massiv dass apple das jetzt erstmal
verschoben hat es geht um ein problem
das richtig massiv ist
nämlich fotos und videos von sexuellem
kindesmissbrauch das wird immer mehr die
polizei ist völlig überfordert mit
dieser menge an material und
kinderschutzorganisationen
sind verzweifelt sie fordern die
gesellschaft muss um kinder zu schützen
solche und ähnliche mechanismen
einsetzen um diese masse herr zu werden
das geht nicht anders aus der it szene
eine hitzige debatte bei der sich
wahrscheinlich keine einfachen lösungen
finden lassen umso wichtiger dass wir
mal drüber reden in diesem video schauen
wir wie groß ist das problem mit fotos
und videos von sexuellen
kindesmissbrauch was hat apple dagegen
vorgeschlagen was kritisieren experten
und datenschützer und was sagen
kinderrechtsorganisationen dazu und ganz
am ende von diesem video wollen wir
schauen ob sich da irgendwie ein
kompromiss finden
bevor wir auf apples umstrittene lösung
schauen müssen wir über die schlimmen
folgen von sexualisierter gewalt gegen
kinder sprechen das sind folgen heute
sehnen leiden menschen wie ihn gefragt
zum beispiel ein leben lang als er
sieben jahre alt war daher kam ein
freund seiner familie hat ihn
missbraucht und hat ihn dann in seinem
freundes und bekanntenkreis eingeführt
und dann dann wohl das immer immer mehr
dann war es endlich so
dass mich meine täter in berlin auf dem
bahnhof zwei sogenannten baby schlecht
bestellt haben und sich daran erfreut
dass fremde männer und freunde mit sechs
an durften das wurde dann auch gesehen
fotografiert das wurden oftmals auch
gegen mich eingesetzt nach dem motto
wenn du was sagst sie haben wir fotos
denkt dran könnten den eltern schule wie
auch immer als irgendwie täter haben
dieses material dann ins netz gestellt
und ingo forte ist sich sicher dass
dieses material in den kreisen immer
noch irgendwo rum geistert also 40 jahre
später dabei ist ganz klar
kindesmissbrauch und material zu
besitzen zu verbreiten zu kaufen das ist
illegal
das darf man in deutschland nicht das
ausmaß des problems das wird immer
krasser allein im vergangenen jahr hat
die amerikanische
kinderschutzorganisation mit
21,7 millionen meldungen über solche
abbildung bekommen jedes jahr werden es
mehr 2020 zählten die behörden in
deutschland 18 1761 fälle von missbrauch
abbildungen im vergleich zum vorjahr ist
das ein anstieg um mehr als die hälfte
aber diese zahlen sind nur das was
polizei und kinderschutzorganisationen
überhaupt mitbekommen die dunkelziffer
ist viel höher die whu schätzt dass bei
uns in deutschland pro schulklasse ein
bis zwei schülerinnen oder schüler
sexueller gewalt ausgesetzt waren oder
noch sind
jährlich bilder und videos davon werden
über das parkett gehandelt aber auch per
mail oder über messenger dienste allein
facebook hat im vergangenen jahr 20
millionen meldungen an mit merck
abgetreten das ist ein netz und der
innenminister von nrw in der pandemie
der sexualisierten gewalt und so kann
man es auch bezeichnend wir sind
überhaupt nicht in der lage dem herr zu
werden ohne digitale mission ist apple
hat im vergangenen jahr 2 165 fälle
gemeldet dies kennen dann noch nicht
systematisch das sind zufallsfunde und
jetzt wollen sie dringend etwas dagegen
tun im august hat apple drei neue
funktionen zum schutz vor
kindesmissbrauch angekündigt erstens
sollen serie und die suche auf dem gerät
eingreifen wenn das verdächtige
suchanfragen nach
missbrauchsdarstellungen von kindern
gibt zweitens soll die nachrichten-app
kinder unter 12 jahren und ihre eltern
warnen wenn kinder fotos geschickt
bekommen auf denen sexuell explizite
inhalte zu sehen sind solche bilder
werden dann erstmal verpixelt und die
eltern werden informiert die dritte
funktion hat aber für besonders viel
wirbel gesorgt es geht darum dass auf
dem gerät alle fotos nach darstellungen
von kindesmissbrauch durchsucht werden
mit dem sogenannten
cash verfahren bevor fotos in die icloud
hochgeladen werden werden sie auf dem
gerät gescannt und dabei mit einer
datenbank abgeglichen die auch auf dem
gerät ist in der datenbank sind
sogenannte herrschers gespeichert man
kann sich solche herrschers vereinfacht
gesagt erstmals eine art digitalen
fingerabdruck vorstellen
allerdings werden solche illegalen fotos
oft verfremdet als zb gespiegelt oder
noch ein filter drüber gelegt oder oder
oder die newron herrschers von apple
sind deshalb keine exakten fingerabdruck
sie erkennen auch fotos die ein bisschen
verändert sind das ergebnis des scans
wird in einer art verschlüsselten
aufkleber gepackt und damit wird das
bild dann hochgeladen bei den ersten
bildern passiert erstmal gar nichts das
könnte auch einen fehler daten seien
aber wenn es häufiger vorkommen die rede
ist von mehr als 30 kunden pushen apple
angestellte die bilder und informieren
dann die kinderschutzorganisation mit
mac die dann die behörden einschalten es
geht also zuerst mal nur um fotos die in
die icloud hochgeladen werden sollen
wobei das ziemlich viele sein dürften
und diese funktion sei auch erstmal nur
in den usa kommen andere länder sollen
dann folgen
die reaktionen auf diese ankündigung
kann sehr schnell und wohl auch deutlich
heftiger als apple das erwartet hätte
innerhalb von ein paar stunden war ein
riesiger aufschrei netz die it
professoren kamera hat prokon so war
einer der lautesten der
größte kritikpunkt ist dass eben nicht
in der cloud oder bei dem netzwerk
gescannt wird wie das google und
facebook messenger jetzt schon machen
sondern auf dem gerät noch bevor es
hochgeladen wird befindet das ist die
eigentliche datenschutzfreundliche
variante leute wie ihr act feld macht
das richtig wütend er ist vorstand im
netz politischen verein.de 64 der der
spd nahe steht und sie haben einen
offenen brief gegen die funktion
unterzeichnet er vergleicht den scannen
mit einem bankschließfach bei apple ist
es nicht mehr so dass ich dieser
zubringer und dann wenn ich es bei der
bank weil sie ein externer link öffnet
der bank mitarbeiter das schließt man
schaut mal rein sondern da wird es so
sein dass wenn ich das zu hause in die
ablagebox läge in der ich dabei ist okay
das bringe ich dann später drehen sich
dass die bank dann steht der
bankmitarbeiter schon daneben und sagen
dann okay alles was wir hier zu hause in
dieser ablagebox liegt da darf ich dann
schon rein gucken und das schulden wir
haben er fürchtet mit der technik wird
es bald nicht mehr nur um cloud inhalte
gehen dann macht das eigentlich nur sinn
wenn man sagt diese person die soll sich
mittelfristig nicht nur das anschauen
was in dieser box die dann auch zur bank
kommt sondern die soll dann vielleicht
auch mal ins regal gucken oder den
schrank was man damals für andere
materialien hat die eigentlich überhaupt
nicht wie die bank bestimmt sind auch
kamerad verkommen so sich diese gefahren
denn das ist mit die securitys gibt denn
das ist
keine politik erstes argument der
kritikerinnen und kritiker ist also der
datenschutz nämlich dass es nicht etwa
unfreiwillig geteilte inhalte geht
sondern um fotos das möglicherweise mit
gar niemandem teilen würde
kinderschutzorganisationen halten
dagegen ja ich seh ich verstehe die
kritik an datenschutz ist ein hohes gut
aber wir haben eine güterabwägung auf
der einen seite ist natürlich der
datenschutz auch für kinder haben ein
recht auf privatsphäre hoch zu retten
auf der anderen seite ist der
kinderschutz ja auch ein
verfassungsrechtlich ist gut die
körperliche unversehrtheit
wir müssen irgendwo abwägen und wir
wegen immer wieder ab und ich glaube die
mechanismen müssen sicher werden auch
gegen missbrauch aber es gibt eine ganz
große befürchtung und die ist dass diese
technik von staaten missbraucht werden
könnte zwei us amerikanische forscher
haben eine ganz ähnliche technik wie die
von apple entwickelt und dann die
forschung eingestellt und begonnen davor
zu warnen die technik sei gefährlich
sagen sie
diese datenbank kann eben nicht nur für
missbrauchs material verwendet werden
sondern auch für alle möglichen arten
von unerwünschten bildern unser system
ließe sich leicht für überwachungs und
zensur zwecke umfunktionieren ein dienst
könnte einfach eine beliebige datenbank
mit passenden inhalten einfügen ohne
dass die personen die diesen dienst
nutzt etwas davon mitbekommt adwords
norden der mal ein ganz ganz düsteres
bild apples vorhaben seines smartphones
dazu zu bringen dass sie ihre besitzer
bespitzeln und verraten ist der beginn
einer dunklen zukunft die mit dem blut
der politischen opposition in 100
ländern geschrieben wird im kern geht es
darum was könnte eigentlich noch alles
dieser scan datenbank hinzugefügt werden
beispiel china wir werden ganz ganz
viele iphones macbooks und so weiter
verkauft und auch produziert was wenn
china sagt ihr dürft bei uns keine
iphones verkaufen wenn ihr nicht diese
inhalte ausführt hat wenn die
chinesische regierung apple die pistole
auf die brust setzen sagt entweder ihr
macht das also hier verwendet sie ihre
gepflegt auch die symbole und grafiken
der uigurischen terroristen und
terroristen das ist ja das branding was
man vor augen haben muss ein die
menschen zivilistinnen und zivilisten
bei uns töten wir wollen die bekämpfung
und entweder ihr pflegt die ein oder ihr
dürft eure druck nicht mehr wir uns auf
dem markt wurde
verbreiten dann
stellt sich ebenfalls schon eher die
frage ob man nicht auch auf so oppel
nicht auch so was er reagieren würde
nicht nur in china sondern auch in
westlichen demokratien zb fürchten
datenschutzorganisationen dass diese
technik für andere zwecke missbraucht
werden könnte und dass diese datenbank
schritt für schritt ausgeweitet wird auf
andere inhalte da muss man nur einen
größeren terroranschlag denken und dann
gibt es dutzende vielleicht hunderte von
toten und dann stellt man sich die frage
wie hätte man das verhindern können und
wenn man dann sagt er auf ein
mobiltelefon der touristinnen und
touristen hat man danach
material bis islamischen staates
entdeckt dann werden wir uns als
gesellschaft mit der frage beschäftigen
mir nicht gewollt dass wir dieses
material vorjahr hätten das gewusst
hätten dass es menschen gibt die dieses
material z und dann hätte man sich die
mal ein bisschen genauer anguckt apple
verteidigt sich und sagt wir nehmen nur
die herrschers von den bildern die in
zwei unterschiedlichen datenbanken von
kinderschutzorganisationen sind staaten
hätten darauf keinen zugriff und
kinderschutzorganisationen halten die
gefahr dass die datenbank zur waffe wird
für gesenkt wenn man das mal ihre kritik
konsequent weiter gedenken würde dann
müsste ich doch rein theoretisch auch
lkws verbieten bei lkws wären sie bereit
stadtplatz berlin ja auch wer ständig
als die waffe gegen menschen eingesetzt
das heißt also nur etwas sozusagen
abstrakt möglich wäre dass ich
missbräuchlich nutzen kann muss ich doch
dann tatsächlich überlegen wie hoch ist
denn sozusagen mein mein bedürfnis dass
ich meine kinder oder jugendlichen
letztendlich schütze dass deren
abbildung gar nicht erst ins märz gelang
und jetzt kann man ja auch eine
aufsichtsbehörde einsetzen oder sonstige
geschichten und letztendlich zu sehen
dass genau dieser dienst auf die
dienstleistung fokussiert wird und nicht
missbräuchlich irgendwie anders genutzt
werden kann neben dieser datenbank gibt
es noch einen weiteren kritikpunkt und
der ist diese herrsching methode die
apple verwenden möchte die ist wohl
fehleranfällig kritisiert
eigentlich ist das system ja genau dafür
konstruiert willen zu erkennen die ein
bisschen verändert worden sind ein
hirsch ist also nicht ein exakter
fingerabdruck sondern er passt zu
verschiedenen bildern mit denselben
eigenschaften aber auch das lässt sich
wohl manipulieren jedenfalls haben
sicher als forscherinnen und
sicherheitsforscher rausgefunden dass
man künstliche bilder erzeugen kann die
denselben erschwert haben zum beispiel
hätte das bild von der katze denselben
erschwert wie dieses bild von dem rund
wenn man weiß welche hashes in der
datenbank sind dann bin ich mir ganz
sicher dass ich in kürzester zeit eine
riesige datenbank völlig harmloser
bilder erstellt werden würde die
aufgrund von veränderungen durch
algorithmische veränderungen mit hilfe
künstlicher intelligenz ist dann
ermöglichen will dann den gleichen hash
wert am ende ausgehen würden so das kann
ich dir schicke in hinreichende anzahl
zumindest das system erst mal ausgelöst
werden würde apple hat zwar für solche
fälle die manuelle überprüfung aber das
system könnte ineffektiv werden und dann
gibt es noch einen weiteren kritikpunkt
den bringt adwords snowden auf den punkt
falls du einen geschäftsmäßiger
pädophiler mit einem keller vollkommen
profitieren das csm iphones sein
solltest erlaubt apple seinen scan
vollständig zu unterbinden indem du
einfach den schalter icloud fotos
deaktivieren um legst eine umgehung die
zeigt dass diese systeme zum schutz von
kindern entwickelt wurde wie sie glauben
machen wollen sondern vielmehr zum
schutz ihrer marke
solange du das material von ihren
servern verhältst und apple damit aus
den schlagzeilen ist dass apple egal den
applaus und die icloud den kann ich
ziemlich schlecht abschalten und ich
denke mir mal mehr als täter solches
material ins netz hochladen kann der
wird doch auch diesen schalter umlegen
oder gerade wenn das jetzt so viel
öffentlich diskutiert wurde joachim türk
vom kinderschutzbund sagt ja aber
das sind das sind die wahrscheinlich
nicht die profis die intranet kinder
anbieten die anderen männer in ihre
stiefkinder anbieten oder kinder diese
irgendwie gefügig gemacht haben die
werden wahrscheinlich nicht über apple
in die cloud das laden und wenn sie es
gemacht haben ab sofort nicht mehr aber
es sind die die angefixt geworden sind
und die
solche bilder laden zum teil ja auch
dann freigegeben um zutritt zu gruppen
zu bekommen und die werden doch nicht
dran denken und die werden dann
erwischte sind vielleicht kleine fische
auf dem weg haie zu werden aber wenn man
die kleinen fische hat und dann wird man
entsprechend möglicherweise weiter gehen
können und dann die großen küche
entdecken das ist meine hoffnung für
kinderschutzorganisationen ist diese
funktion also eine große hoffnung aber
apple hat wohl nicht damit gerechnet
dass der widerstand dagegen so groß ist
zuerst mal haben sie ein paar pds
hochgeladen um nochmal zu erklären was
das eigentlich bringen soll und dann
haben sie einen hochrangigen manager ins
interview geschickt um die wogen zu
glätten die filter dass du soll sich
unabhängig überprüfen lassen und es soll
eine datenbank weltweit geben damit
starten sich da nicht einmischen können
trotzdem hat die kritik nicht aufgehört
und deswegen hat apple diese funktion
und jetzt erstmal vertagt
basierend auf dem feedback von kunden
interessensgruppen forschern und anderen
haben wir beschlossen und von den
kommenden monaten zusätzlich zeit zu
nehmen um input zu sammeln und
verbesserungen vorzunehmen bevor wir
diese äußerst wichtigen funktionen für
die sicherheit von kindern
veröffentlichen ja es stimmt das muss
man wirklich mehr gegen diese
missbrauchsdarstellungen getan werden
ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen
wir belasten das ist ein solches
material von einem im umlauf ist ich
muss mich damit auseinander setzung
nicht nur ich sondern die der andere hat
auch das jetzt gerade zum beispiel
probiert dieses gespräch führen
irgendjemand irgendwo auf der welt
irgendein täter oder der täterin oder
jemand der sich das gerne anschaut
genauso ich mein material anschaut ich
möchte mir nicht vorstellen was er dabei
den tut oder so etwas gemeinsam ist
allen klar dass das tatsächlich
sozusagen immer im netz bleiben wird das
heißt ich werde eigentlich tagtäglich
digital wieder missbraucht und
gleichzeitig kann ich auch die großen
sorgen von datenschützern und digital
vereinen verstehen stellt sich die frage
gibt dass da irgendein kompromiss eine
lösung für dieses massive probleme von
missbrauchsdarstellungen netz dass wir
auch eine aufforderung alle die das
jetzt kritisieren mitzuhelfen dass es
sicherer wird aber die die chance oder
die aufforderung jetzt nichts zu tun
kann ich nicht akzeptieren
bei tausenden von missbrauchs fällen
können wenn ich kann nicht sagen dass
die blick werden die infos bisschen eine
andere form gefunden wird
der zweck ist eine komplett in
deutschland
da stellen sich zwei so wichtiger
grundsatz dagegen war in diesem konflikt
ein kompromiss zu finden eine lösung zu
finden
das wird glaube ich richtig schwer
[Musik]
schützt so ein feature er die täter oder
droht mit zu einer funktion massenhaft
überwachung schreibt es uns in den
kommentaren
das würde mich echt interessieren
außerdem haben wir euch hier noch ein
summen verlinkt und ganz wichtig wenn
ihr selbst von sexuellem missbrauch
betroffen seien wir haben euch unten in
der beschreibung nummern aufgeschrieben
dahin könnt euch wenden und tut das auch
ihr seid nicht allein